Speaker 1: You know, over the last couple of
years, few years, it's become this default
refrain from the right that social media is
left wing and it amplifies left wing messages
and ideas. It suppresses right wing messages and
ideas, sometimes by prioritizing the content,
sometimes by straight up a banning the purveyors
of the content, et cetera. Most of us understand
this, but very often it's easy to kind of get
lost in the messaging when the real way to look at
these claims is to look at them empirically. Now,
Facebook is one that has been very much under fire
by the right. The ban of Trump became a flashpoint
in this case to be made that many of them are
making that all these platforms, including
Facebook, just want to prop up leftwing messages
and ideology. But intuitively, it didn't really
ever seem that that was the case with Facebook.
I've mentioned to you anecdotally, Ben Shapiro
does so well, one of the top Facebook publishers
and Dan Bongino we've talked about and all these
right wingers. It seems that between that and Mark
Zuckerberg kind of at minimum, looking the other
way when it comes to the way that the right used
Facebook to spread disinformation about the
election and vaccines, et cetera, certainly
doesn't seem that Facebook is propping up the
left. Media Matters undertook a very interesting
investigation and quantified a lot of this, and
it found that the top political posts on Facebook
are almost always and almost exclusively right
wing. I've mentioned this before. Every day,
Media Matters uses Facebook's CrowdTangle
tool to identify and share the top the 10
posts with the most interactions from top
political and use related Facebook pages.
Our list also specifies the ideological leaning.
Media Matters and others have demonstrated again
and again there is no bias or censorship against
conservatives on Facebook, despite claims to the
contrary. The dataset is more evidence that
no such bias exists. Here is a sample day,
but a typical day on Facebook. This was two days
ago, so Monday you look at the top 10 Facebook
posts about news and politics. It was Breitbart,
Don Junior, Ben Shapiro. Franklin Graham,
another Breitbart. The Hodge twins. Fox News and
Ben Shapiro. Eight out of the 10 are hard right,
hard right posts. One of the top 10 posts is the
link from NPR, and we'll look at it in a second,
which is considered nonaligned ideology. The
right says NPR leans left. NPR is sticks to facts
overwhelmingly in their news reporting. And then
one is a Hillary Clinton post. But wait until I
show you what the Hillary Clinton post actually
is. So 80 percent of the top Facebook news and
politics post Monday Conservative. Now we go
and we actually look at what the posts are.
The Breitbart post is about standing by Aaron
Rodgers despite his lies about being vaccinated.
OK, that's like a hard propaganda post.
The second one is a Don Jr. post with a
picture of Don senior Donald Trump that
says Miss him yet! Not very substantive.
The Ben Shapiro post is one about it's called a
boom. Man shot by Rittenhouse admits he pointed
a gun at Rittenhouse. The Hillary Clinton
post is just a New York City marathon picture
of. I believe that that's Chelsea Clinton. It's
it's not even political. It's from Hillary,
but it's just someone who ran the marathon. So
it's not even political in the sense that these
other posts are political. There's a Franklin
Graham post about his heart surgery that he got.
And then the NPR post is about conservatives
being mad about Big Bird getting vaccinated,
so even the NPR posts that made it is one that
appeals to conservatives because it's about the
uprising from the right about Big Bird announcing
that he got a COVID vaccine. So even when we look
at these 10 top 10 posts on Facebook from November
8th, the one that's left leaning is just a picture
of someone who ran the marathon. It's not even
a left wing message, and the one from NPR, which
is considered nonaligned politically, is one that
would be particularly appealing to conservatives.
So what's the takeaway here? The takeaway is when
you broadly hear this platform favors the left or
that platform favors the left, you might say that
sounds reasonable, or you might say it doesn't
sound reasonable, but we are able to quantify
these things. We are able to quantify it. And at
least as far as Facebook goes routinely, this is
not an outlier day routinely. The top performers
are almost exclusively right wing publishers.
Let me know your thoughts. You can find me on
Twitter at Packman. We're going to take a quick
break. We'll talk about the Aaron Rodgers apology.
We're going to talk about the judge's decision
in the Trump riot documents. We're going to talk
about the Paul Gosar video where he's depicted as
killing AOC in animal form. All of it is upcoming.
Find me on Twitter at De Packman. Remember that
our program depends on the support of viewers and
listeners like you. We have a membership program
you can sign up and within. It's really 45 seconds
with average computer skills. You can sign up at
Join Packman dot com. You'll get an extra show
every day produced just for our members. You'll
get a commercial free audio and video stream
of the show and lots of other great perks.
Join Pacman Dot Com is the place to sign up.